I want to start by thanking of course
Jana and Randy for organizing this event
but I just I feel sort of hot we
couldn't have a Mormon gathering without
some tears I feel very overwhelmed by
what clouded the gift claudia has given
us with these oral histories it's such
an important important projects and for
her ability as it's just a senior
scholar in our field bringing these
voices into the room here today of these
Mormon women speaking from a diversity
of perspectives I just really want to
acknowledge the work she's done and say
how moving I find it and how grateful I
am for it and now I'm going to stop
crying or try oh and I actually say to
that um I have my own personal narrative
of prop 8 and I wrote about it in a book
I've just published and there's a few
copies outside and you can get one if
you want and but I'm gonna try and talk
today even though I lived in California
and during the time of the YES on 8
campaign I'm gonna try and talk today as
a scholar sort of trying to analytically
tease out different threads I saw and
put them together with larger patterns
in Mormon history and culture to help
make sense of what exactly it was that
we experienced that fall um okay so just
for some background um proposition 8 was
a 2008 ballot initiative that
successfully amended the California
state constitution to abolish existing
rights of same-sex couples to marry
civilly although the real muscle and I
want to be clear about this the real
muscle behind proposition 8 was
homophobia right statewide general
everybody homophobia Mormons played a
dominant role in the YES on 8 campaign
in June 2008 a letter from the First
Presidency of the church was read over
the pulpit during Sunday sacrament
meetings asking members to quote do all
you can in support of proposition 8 to
abolish same-sex marriage by late August
2008 the church had organized selective
solicitation conference calls wherein
members of the quorum of the seventy the
high-ranking body of Mormon officials
asked potential large donors to give
$25,000 per family to protect marriage
calm after a surge in five figure
donations began to appear on state donor
record
in early September large and small-scale
giving continued so that by the end of
the campaign it is estimated that
individual Mormons who make up two
percent of California's population
contributed between fifty and seventy
percent of the forty million dollars
raised by YES on eight LDS congregations
had also been mobilized as precinct
Walker's phone bankers zip code area
supervisors and child care providers in
voter identification and
get-out-the-vote efforts for a
far-reaching and professionally
orchestrated grassroots campaign in many
areas of California Mormons constituted
the majority of the on-the-ground
grassroots political operation while
Mormons as far away as Massachusetts
were solicited for donations and members
as far away as Idaho ready to
participate in phone banks after a
contentious five-month campaign that
cost eighty three million dollars the
most expensive social policy initiative
in United States history proposition 8
passed by a margin of about 52 to 48
percent why this intensity
how did Mormons understand our own
participation in the YES on 8 campaign
we've heard David Campbell's speak
earlier today about Mormon populations
as dry kindling and attributing they're
ready mobilization to the strongly
centralized hierarchical organization of
the church and emphasis on obedience to
LDS church leadership but not every
socially conservative cause elicits such
a response from LDS church members what
happened with proposition 8 was at LDS
Church officials and Mormon political
operatives successfully particularized
the YES on 8 campaign in terms of LDS
theology and historical experience LDS
people were led to experience
proposition 8 as an assault by broader
society on what Mormons had for more
than a century perceived to be an
imperiled form the Mormon temple
marriage this triggered century-old
tensions between Mormons and American
civil society over
questions of family definition theocracy
and state sovereignty tensions that
revealed themselves in the discourse of
the campaign today I'm going to examine
how patterns of discourse first
developed among Mormons during open
conflict over polygamy have shaped
Mormon participation in American
political life including the YES on 8
campaign and just decided I think I just
polygamy
I had an early heard this papered I just
think polygamy is as two Mormon history
of slavery as to American history it's
just it's pervasive foundational it's
pervasive it's persistent and its
effects it's still very much with us
even though it's not necessarily
acknowledged as such according to
anthropologist Damon Smith polygamy
fostered the development of discursive
strategies ways of talking and thinking
used by Mormons to maintain their
theocratic sovereignty in the face of
federal colonization working from Smith
I identify five discursive strategies
one theological and discursive
construction of the temple sealed family
as a unit of LDS theocracies with LDS
temples as its emblem to preference for
information through authorized channels
and general distrust of non
institutional sources on Mormonism three
adoption of a defensive default posture
of non transparency in public relations
a stance captured in the phrase mind
your own business also known in the late
19th century as the Mormon Creed number
four cultivation of insider and outsider
narratives and number five the use of
carefully managed public speech to
protect private knowledge I call this
complex of discursive tactics under
grounding after the 19th century Mormon
underground at Harvard Mormon men and
women evading prosecution for polygamy
or unlawful cohabitation even after the
polygamy crisis years past these tactics
of undergrounding contributed to the
development of a Mormon ethos privileges
opacity institutional loyalty hierarchy
and guardedness
as assimilating LDS communities
maintained
the residual theocratic difference and
maybe later we can talk about
guardedness and opacity and certain
presidential candidate the kernel of
this undergrounding strategy is this a
split between private or insider
communication and public communication
that manifests in practices of social
insularity Mormons preferring to marry
socialize discuss faith with other
Mormons and in the careful use of public
speech as sort of a protective or
deflective action rather than
communicative reason the assumed speech
norm of modern civic life's right so
that you know the comp the social
compact modernity agrees on is that we
we speak it doesn't always work this way
where we think of speech as being
communicative and rational and supposed
to convey something a different sense of
speech obtains I'm suggesting in some
warmest situations where public speech
is actually management of private
information sort of deflection and
management of private information Mormon
studies scholars continue to speak about
this public-private split contributing
to a divided sense of self among Mormons
and related habits of double coding in
public speech especially in situations
where LDS people perceive a threat to
their way of being
that's how California Mormons were led
to view the legalization of same-sex
marriage the construction of the YES on
8 campaign as a last-ditch defense of
LDS temple marriage practices
reactivated Mormon discursive tactics of
undergrounding developed under the
pressure of the 19th century Battle of
polygamy I'm gonna review some of these
like attributes of this Mormon sort of
discursive habits and how they should
manifest materialized drug Proposition 8
first preference for information through
authorized channel in general distrust
of non institutional sources on
Mormonism the YES on 8 campaign yet the
LDS YES on 8 campaign
operationalized Mormon preference for
information through authorized LDS
channels and distrust of non
institutional sources a pattern that
dates back to polygamy Mormons did not
receive their information about
Proposition 8 through general campaign
media instead specifically Mormon
campaign content was developed and
distributed through familiar
institutional channels letters over the
pulpit instructions from priests
leaders and congregations and donation
solicitation and videoconference
training by members of the quorum of the
seventy a second set of surrogate
institutional channels bearing a trusted
conservative LDS brand was also
established particularly through
conservative online LDS Meridian
magazine a third set of trusted insider
channels during the campaign where
Mormon kinship networks families friends
wards and reporter McKay Coppins has a
great piece out in BuzzFeed today about
how the Romney campaign is kind of using
some of these networks among Mormons the
friends and family network to turn out
volunteers which horizontally
distributed discourse and argumentation
through face-to-face and online
interaction so effective were these
horizontal kinship networks that during
their October 8 teleconference training
LDS church officials encouraged members
to use this horizontal messaging
institutional channels branded
surrogates and kinship networks all
served as the primary trusted source of
information for LDS people during the
YES on 8 campaign public sources were
disregarded or regarded with distrust
number two adoption of a default
defensive posture of non transparency in
public relations
aka mind your own business second the
church established through its
surrogates a defensive organizational
posture public non-transparency the
operational equivalent of the mind your
own business creed just as authorized
campaign communications were fed into
Mormon communities through LDS
institutional and surrogate channels
surrogate channels of campaign
mobilization that piggybacked onto LDS
church structures initially gave the
church a layer of public layer of
protection against public scrutiny even
before the proposition 8 campaign
observers of the LGBT civil rights
movement had tracked close ties between
the LDS Church and national
anti-marriage equality organizations
like the National Organization for
Marriage during the YES on 8 campaign
church members were instructed to
recognize protectmarriage.com as the
authorized surrogate LDS campaign agency
protectmarriage.com organized a
grassroots operational arm that was
distinguished on paper at least from
ecclesiastical structures but what
in fact piggybacked on to geographically
organized ecclesiastical units so Ward's
so regions of the campaign in the
grassroots language were mapped on to
stakes in the church operate an
institution institutional structure and
zip code supervisors to do the
canvassing were assigned by wards
regional directors and zip code
supervisors were authorized to assign
campaign responsibilities within their
wards and stakes in a practice that
piggybacked on the LDS ecclesiastical
practice of assigning members callings
financially the church also deferred to
and directed members to support
protectmarriage.com it did not make a
direct major donation to the campaign as
it had in Alaska instead it assisted
with fundraising assessments and
directed members to donate to protect
marriage calm only church members were
advised to conduct the campaign in ways
that might shield the church from
scrutiny or deflect attention LDS
volunteers who did door-to-door voter
identification were encouraged not to
self-identify as Mormons some members
regarded these instructions in the use
of surrogates that piggybacked on to
church structures confusing indeed
it what you know it's sort of the main
utility of this sort of surrogate
structure I understand top it like
here's the campaign grassroots structure
here's the war instruction where mormons
show up and organized layered
distinguished on paper but commingled
i'm and sort of the main utility of this
it seems was to provide sort of a
plausible layer of protection against
the church being identified as a major
direct stakeholder a few more
observations third the YES on 8 campaign
fostered private insider narratives that
constructed protection of LDS temple
ceilings as its objects so it once again
this public-private split in the way
Mormons narrate their realities within
insider organizational channels the way
LDS people talked amongst themselves
about the YES on 8 campaign differed
from the ways they talked about the
campaign in public while it's true that
on both channels the scripted narrative
was that a vote for proposition 8 was a
vote to protect marriage LDS people
narrated the YES on 8 campaign as an
urgent defense of temple marriage in
particular insider LDS communications
about prop
eight depicted marriage equality as an
assault on the ability of the LDS Church
to continue to perform temple marriages
constructing the campaign as a defense
of the temple in July 2008 Meridian
magazine published from protect marriage
grassroots director Gary Lawrence who is
LDS and whose firm Lawrence research was
contracted by the campaign an article
that framed the proposition 8 campaign
in Mormon theological terms as the
sacred war in defense of religious
agency quote a defining moment a tipping
point a critical battle in our existence
and I want you to mind this this is not
about those people is about our
existence right a tipping point on
August 9th 2008 Meridian published an
article by Lawrence's grassroots
co-director Glen greener presenting 9
talking points alleging that failure to
prep passed Proposition 8 would result
in government intrusions on religious
liberties including lawsuits against
churches that refused to perform
same-sex marriages shortly thereafter a
redacted six consequences if proposition
8 does not pass document created by Gary
Lawrence went viral throughout Mormon
organizational and kinship networks what
was not said explicitly in the six
consequences document was elaborated in
the insider narratives of the Mormon YES
on 8 campaign those who witnessed the
campaign firsthand in California report
that it was communicated by priests to
leaders and Sunday meetings and widely
believed among LDS Church members that
the legalization of same-sex marriage
would force the LDS Church to marry gay
couples and that the church would be
forced to shut down its own temples
rather than comply similar narratives
were deployed among LDS church members
in Arizona and Massachusetts when those
states considered same-sex marriage
legalization Mormons generally did not
incorporate their fear of a threat
against temple marriage in their
communications with non Mormon potential
voters because that would have
contradicted instructions not to openly
identify as LDS but day to day member
communications day to day member to
member communications consistently
telegraphed this threat in language
coded to index the Mormon temple for
example when zip code supervisor
described door to door voter
identification as
duty another described phone-banking as
a responsibility with eternal
consequences the idea that the
legalization of same-sex marriage would
force conservative denominations to
offer marriage to same-sex couples or
face legal penalty was broadly
discredited by experts writing in the
mainstream media Mormon supporters of
marriage equality also sought to contest
this contentious interpretation but
their efforts were broadly disregarded
because they did not reach LDS
populations through trusted recognized
institutional and authorized surrogate
channels the siege oriented
undergrounding mentality insulated LDS
populations from robust civil exchange
with fellow citizens there is no
question that when discursive tactics of
undergrounding were used during the YES
on 8 campaign they effectively motivated
and mobilized LDS people but
reactivating these old patterns of
guardedness sees mentality opacity and
insider-outsider boundary maintenance
also came perhaps at a cost to LDS
credibility in the weeks and months that
followed the campaign LDS and non-lds
activists documented the extent of
church backed LDS involvement in the
campaign including the large proportion
of LDS on eight money that came from LDS
people making up a small fraction of the
California population because the church
had successfully deflected attention
from its own heavy investment and
proposition 8 by mobilizing insulated
internal channels of communication using
surrogates to deflect attention and
fostering private siezure narratives to
motivate LDS public sphere participation
post-election documentation of Mormon
participation in the campaign took on a
sensational air as a drama of
concealment and revelation rouse and
it's revealed that Mormons had this huge
handin has revealed all of a sudden such
coverage fostered a sense in the public
of outing a cloaked but pervasive Mormon
influence harkening back to and
seemingly confirming 19th century
stereotypes of Mormon deception and
untrustworthiness okay here's an image
you're probably you may be familiar with
this is an image that circulated during
the hearings at the time of the seating
of Senator Reid Smoot in the early 20th
century the first LDS senator multi-year
show trial was convened as kathleen
flake has brilliantly covered in her
book putting basically Mormons on trial
to determine whether they're worthy to
serve and this image shows the Mormon
hierarchy and Smoot is the small
puppet-like figure in its hands and on
the arm it says polygamy murder of
apostates blood atonement so there's a
sense it says the real objection to
Smoots is the caption and then here's
the image from the film the Mormon
proposition Evo's sir the Mormon
Proposition 8 the Mormon proposition
notice the parallels here of the idea of
a cloaked influence notice - how the
pullquote selected by the producers of 8
the movie position Mormons as a
population unwilling to participate in
open dialogue as much as I reject
negative stereotypes of LDS people
wherever they occur these images point
to some painful realities most Mormons
were only marginally aware of the
tactics of insularity deflection and
careful management implemented by the
grassroots yes on 8 campaign
I mean yes on 8 activities were
conducted in plain sight in LDS
communities and LDS people were
encouraged to view themselves as part of
a coalition to same sex to end same-sex
marriage consequently Mormons were
unprepared for the sensationalistic
outing of a Mormon underground or a
Mormon influence and bewildered by the
activists response focusing on LDS
participation including temples by LGBT
folks at LDS temples in California and
beyond such demonstrations recursively
confirmed the construction of the LDS
temple as an emblem of besieged
theocracy and heightened the sense among
Mormons that LDS life ways were under
threat from a hostile secular world
Mormons were also seemingly unprepared
for the idea that their disproportionate
and carefully managed involvement in the
SNA
campaign would brand the church as a
leading opponent of LGBT equality
nationwide all of these consequences
highlight the general non alignment
between internal LDS discourse and
public sphere discourse understanding
the insularity privacy and residual
theocracy of LDS communities is crucial
to understanding Mormon participation in
American political life Mormons have not
routinely mobilized on social
conservative issues like abortion rights
that have motivated other conservative
Christian denominations but if directed
by LDS church leaders to mobilize on an
issue that has perceived impact LDS
interests they will do so with intensity
the primary site for these interventions
has been at issues of gender especially
as they pertain to family definition in
as much as the power to create and bind
families is a primary distinguishing
feature of LDS theocracy this pattern
has held through for more than a century
from the political crisis over polygamy
to the Equal Rights Amendment to
proposition 8 even as we have
transitioned from the frontier theocracy
to minority denominational status
Mormons have maintained amongst
ourselves a strong sense of
differentiation from and a residually
martial disposition towards dominant
society a robust sense of our history
vibrant kinship networks and
oppositional identity our political
assets to the Mormon tradition old
patterns of undergrounding are the
shadow side of our difference how Mormon
communities continue to manage this
shadow side and what it costs us will be
key determinants of Mormon participation
in American politics in the 21st century
thank you
thank you both Claudia and Johanna for
your papers and we have time for robust
discussion yeah the question was will we
see this intensity of participation
again you know in other states there's a
contest in Minnesota that's approaching
a ballot initiative and you know I'm I
think California is in some ways a
unique space or a special space I think
I forget who it was that said I think
David might have said that you know the
inside word is that the church felt it
could make a difference in California I
mean there's a there's a strong
multi-generational Mormon community in
California small but big enough to have
sort of a critical mass there's some
patterns of wealth distribution among
California Mormons that could be readily
mobilized I mean the population is so
much smaller in Minnesota that I don't
think we are seeing this kind of
mobilization I mean there's been several
contests that have passed without us
seeing mobilization as directed by the
church rise to this level so I don't I
don't know I don't think that we'll see
this again on on valid initiatives
pertaining to marriage equality
can I ask people use the microphone if
possible if not speak loudly Sally
well I would say certainly there is a
connection and but what I see is the
common denominator is this kind of
conservative fear what if you know if
this happens then you list a whole list
of possible results that will come and
you know how many times have people that
have been in the trenches like me heard
and it's not what you're doing now it's
what you might do down the line and so I
think it's very similar to that we just
read the future ahead and it doesn't
necessarily come to pass I mean there
may be something to this this idea I
think you're trying to race I like that
there's this sort of allergy to polygamy
in the commune like a very complicated
contradictory relationship to polygamy
that still persists in Mormon culture
you know there are folks you know
mainstream members who believe it
polygamy may be the order of the
afterlife you know that's just a part of
us that's still with us and at the same
time you know during the S on a campaign
you'd find younger people who really
didn't know about the church's
polygamist past because it has been sort
of edited out of curriculum believe it
or not there are young people who just
this is not a part of their awareness
young Mormon people yeah people are
nodding their heads yeah young people
are nodding their heads didn't tell you
yeah no but into and so I think this
allergy this highly conflicted
relationship to the polygamist past sort
of led to really strange moments during
the campaign intense moments where more
mister you know faced with commentators
would say but you all have the queerest
form of marriage going in the 19th
century who us what are you talking
about or young Mormons espousing the
parade of horribles line of reasoning
you know which is owned next is x y&z
polygamy is awful from young Mormon
people
I'll say we need those who were here
this morning on the balance will freak
and this question honoring the LSD
community so this question comes what I
could make clear to me what the heck
reasoning the government used from a
legal point of view - I personally would
you mind so what you know what I'm
starting to make light in this but what
was the government's reasoning for
disallowing Sally that the question was
what was the government's reasoning for
outlawing polygamy in nineteen side then
you have the expert right here
I guess everybody saw Sandra Day
O'Connor's quip yesterday that of these
two potential nominees for Republican
nomination one of them was a practicing
polygamist and he wasn't even a Mormon
other questions an argument that Sally
brought up towards the end of her
presentation this morning and that was
with the rise of kind of lawyers as a
class and legal thinking in the
territory of Utah towards the end of the
polygamy struggle and as you know Utah
developed its position as a stage women
who had been so very very active in both
the defense of ballooning and then the
attack on believe me found themselves
marginalize found themselves set aside
and so as you have studied
18th century Mormon feminism I wonder
was there lunch vocalized expression of
regret at the passing of polygamy
because this was their opportunity to be
vocal proponents to be strong voices
within the public sphere and as the
debate moved in a different direction
did they feel that power was being taken
away and did they I don't have a lot of
evidence on that myself and there's at
least that one state when comment from a
woman who was there when polygamy was
voted out in the tabernacle and I voted
for it because there was nothing else to
do even knowing it would make me not a
wife again and and homeless possibly and
to you know if my children just said
aside you know so I think the real
victims of this as Sally said today a
lot of the real victims I don't think
she mentioned specifically where the
plural wives that are just thrown to the
dogs I mean what it but you know you
read their individual stories and they
don't complain about not having the
political position they complain about
not having a house and a husband and
things like that you know it was a
terrible wrench for society and for
these women who done all the things they
were supposed to do for all those years
against all kinds of fun you know all
kinds of effort by others here at the am
I just lost yeah it's it's a tragic
situation I think
Jim
after the reaction to and I said that I
thought the Brethren the general were
surprised and their reaction do you
think that was put on or do you think
they really were surprised at the
reaction I should think so it was really
I was in California then and it was with
a striking situation some of it I mean
and we just don't have enough
documentation there's just not enough
documented historical sources yet
available you know I hope they will be
one of the narratives that circulates in
California is that that folks at some of
the regional and kind of grassroots the
campaign people in California sort of
took the ball and ran with it in a way
that may have exceeded expectations from
Salt Lake yeah you know so the
grassroots organized the grassroot the
statewide professional grassroots
personnel who were Mormons developed
plans that may have exceeded
expectations when the first presidency
issued a letter saying please do all
that you can so that's that's a
narrative that's circulated but again
it's very difficult to document without
access to archives
this is a great a very timely question
just in the last week we've seen
articles and Reuters and Peggy's written
about it for the Salt Lake Tribune about
how access to information in the digital
age is creating a new landscape of
knowledge about church history and you
know I've even I mean I'm nobody and
I've got an email from parents who say
my son googled something and landed in a
site about Joseph Smith and polygamy and
what he read made him dissipate from the
tradition you know so there's a real
moment unfolding and it's going to
intensify with the scrutiny of the
campaign year ahead
when aspects of Mormon history that have
been very carefully managed for I
believe you know people who believe they
have best intentions
mokou lighting with the Google era so
it's gonna be interesting to see how
this all unfolds I mean it's it's tricky
and it's in process right now that's
actually sort of a it was really strong
when you used two hands and said well on
one hand we've got
how much of what we are dealing with now
and maybe even now meaning Mormonism
because we're young religion but there
are some aspects like you said Joanna
Google is new and all of these things
were some of these new dynamics are
there religious traditions communities
are there histories that you're aware of
you sort of the Mormons you're aware of
are looking this way well alright I'll
talk fast and then Joanna can give us
the right answer but I we've been
reading for our class in contemporary
Mormonism arm and mossis piece about his
updating if the angel and the Beehive
for he talks about how the great
pressure to retrench that has to become
more conservative has led up in the last
two decades and he's the figures he asks
why and he says he thinks it's because
the tension between being a Mormon and
living in the contemporary world is just
a little too much right now and has to
be be relieved and so it's very
interesting to look at that along with a
number of specific issues you know how
do you feel about the infallibility of
the Prophet how do you believe about
behavior on all kinds of things what
about the history of the Book of Mormon
because those and many other subjects
have gone back and forth along the
spectrum and we do have in the church a
wide spectrum of belief on all of these
things now you asked specifically what
things well it seems to me that the
church historical department has now
done the job on Mountain Meadows
Massacre I don't know if there's
anything left to be found they
certainly done an exhaustive search I
have heard that plans or at least
discussions about doing the same thing
with polygamy to explore everything
everything and then lay it all out
things like that are in the works and we
certainly seen that piece that Peggy did
the other day where Marlin Jensen was
talking to Phil Barlow's class and how
he said that knowing many people were
disturbed about things they discovered
that they were going to make an effort
to disseminate much more of that
information much earlier so those are
the things I'd say I think a great deal
about Kathleen Flakes narrative about
Mormonism moving from sort of a
theocracy and then taking on forms of
denominationalism right just another
American denomination as part of its
price of entry into 20th century life
and I think that transition is ongoing
you know I think there's still a
residual sense of theocracy and that
Mormons haven't necessarily settled into
a sense that we're just like you were
sort of inferring for just another a
religious minority right we have
experiences like any other people of
faith you need transition into different
stages of faith over the course of your
life of course there's still something
different more Murs like to reserve
about ourselves and not sort of just
join the plurality of American faiths
and and it'll be interesting to see how
we continue to manage this transition
over the course of the 21st century and
I'm always thrilled when I hear that you
know there I think the church is in a
great job dressing Mountain Meadows I
frankly as someone who knows Native
American history I always scratch my
heads when people get up in too much
well not even say that I mean massacres
happened in the American West a lot you
know and it's less that these issues I
think any of them individually are so
destructive to us but the way that we
try to manage them and people know when
we are trying to manage our information
people know people can sense that we
have more to fear and the way we handle
our own issues than
issues themselves